hey guys today we're gonna talk about
potassium and I don't know if you knew
this but the prehistoric diet was very
high in potassium currently an average
male consumes about 3,000 milligrams
potassium honestly I think it's less
than that but these are these are the
numbers that I got women about a little
more than 2000 milligrams of potassium
okay per day the RDA for potassium is
4700 prehistorically and there's limited
data on this but the data that I found
ranges between 7,000 and 15,000
milligrams of potassium that's a lot of
potassium our bodies need a lot of
potassium for many reasons one is that
each cell has a sodium potassium pump so
it uses a lot of those minerals to
create energy and move things around in
the body prehistorically potassium was
consumed through greens tubers and roots
I'm gonna recommend stick with the
greens and not do any type of potatoes
but the body is very flexible with
potassium if it has too much it gets rid
of it if it doesn't have enough it does
retain it and also when you're doing in
a minute fasting you will conserve
potassium and you won't need as much
okay fYI but the body does hold sodium
so what's even a little bit more
important than the quantity of these
minerals is the ratio of the minerals
you need four times as much potassium to
sodium an average person in America has
a one to four ratio very light on the
potassium very heavy on the sodium not
even from the foods but from the refined
carbs that deplete potassium and then
ahold sodium so when you do a high carb
diet you're holding a lot of sodium and
you're in you're losing on a potassium
so you have this severe imbalance so
when your potassium deficient or you're
on a potassium deficiency I mean meaning
that you're not consuming enough
vegetables you tend to get high blood
pressure and a high pulse rate
eventually
kidney stones insulin resistance one way
to improve insulin resistance is to
increase your potassium when you have
insulin resistance you can't absorb
potassium but taking more can improve
insulin resistance but not having enough
can throw off your blood sugars big-time
not having enough potassium can increase
your risk of stroke one big symptom is
fatigue and low endurance you go to the
gym you just don't have that vitality
can't last that long also you increases
your risk for cardiac hypertrophy what
does that mean it means the heart
actually enlarges when you take
potassium and actually can go to the
normal size that it needs the problem
though when you go to your doctor and
get your potassium assess is they're
looking in the blood outside the cell
well only 2% of your potassium reserves
are outside the cell 98% are inside the
cell that's why they're gonna miss it
you have to do a special test which is
intracellular potassium and the way
people are deficient in potassium is
they're not consuming enough of the
right foods okay so I'm going to show
you in my book this book okay
I'm page 122 I listed a lot of
vegetables okay so what you're going to
notice when you read this is that most
of the foods on this list are so high in
potassium and so low in sodium it's not
even the four to one ratio it's probably
like 12 to 1 okay but we do need some
sea salt for sure especially when you're
doing in a bit of fasting and healthy
ketosis but the point I'm trying to
bring up is that when you do ketosis
make sure you do it healthily and make
sure you do foods that are high in
potassium it just so happens though
those foods are also high in magnesium
the two top minerals that most people
are deficient in now high sugar diets
will deplete potassium refined
carbohydrates will deplete potassium and
stress will do it too so this is why if
you go through surgery for example they
may give you some potassium in an IV
before hand or during because the high
levels of stress that occur under
surgery can deplete your potassium
levels interesting so anything with
stress injury shock surgery you need
more potassium if you don't have enough
in your reserve you can have all sorts
of problems alright guys thanks for
watching so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that